les länder politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'hebdo
politique votre rendez vous politique du
dimanche soir sur radio sensations en
association avec tv 78 épisodes 198
notre invité ce soir et laurence rochât
[Musique]
lève tôt politique
laurence trochut bonsoir ben ça vous
êtes conseillère départementale des
yvelines et présidente du mouvement
conservateur
le département des yvelines est durement
touchée par le terrorisme en 2016 un
couple de policiers a été tué à
magnanville il y a un an c'était
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit qui
marquait le pays
2021 place votre département encore une
fois dans le deuil avec cette attaque à
rambouillet c'est une nouvelle épreuve
c'est une épreuve c'est une épreuve bien
sûr avec toute la tristesse que c'est
que ces événements génèrent parce que
derrière il ya des vies ya des familles
et on sait que ce sont à chaque fois des
drames
c'est un drame aussi pour notre pays
parce que derrière toutes ces attaques
qui visent des personnes c'est aussi la
france qui est visé et là il ya aussi de
la colère il ya de la colère parce que
nous nous sommes attaqués et la question
qui se pose immanquablement c'est de
savoir est ce que nous savons riposté ou
en tout cas ce que nous avons riposté
avec les bons outils et là il ya de la
colère par rapport justement à ces demi
mesures prises par le par le
gouvernement qui ne permettent pas
d'enrayer en fait cette cette vague
d'attaqués terroristes et c'est vague de
délinquance parce que là on est bien sûr
en tant qu yvelinois directement touché
par par ces attentats et puis il ya
aussi toute la délinquance de tous les
jours mais qui n'est pas je dirais
simplement de l'ordre du fait divers fin
je vois que par exemple une femme a été
brûlée à mérignac brûlée vive à mérignac
je vois que la nuit dernière encore à
villeurbanne il ya un policier qui qui
s'est pris un tournevis dans la main
voilà et ses violences en fait qui sont
faites aussi contre nos institutions
eh bien c'est la france qui est attaquée
et la colère vient de ce que aujourd'hui
quand on regarde les parcours en fait
des assaillants quand il s'agit de
terroristes ou les parcours des
délinquants quand il s'agit de crimes ou
de tentatives de crime et bien on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de faire le lien
entre délinquance terrorisme et
immigration et je suis pas là en train
de dire que tous les terroristes où tous
les délinquants sont des immigrés je
suis simplement là en train de doses et
pointer un sujet sur lequel beaucoup
trop ferme les yeux au motif que parce
qu'on est un pays ouvert et bien il ne
faudrait pas posé sur la table tous les
éléments du sujet et là il ya de la
colère justement le 23 avril dernier une
fonctionnaire de police a été tué dans
une attaque au couteau
vous avez décrit cet acte comme je cite
une barbarie islamiste
le gouvernement est il trop laxiste avec
l'immigration vous savez c'est une
question de volonté politique les remet
dans les eaux depuis longtemps mais ils
ne sont pas appliqués et là pour le coup
c'est vrai que contre le coc vide
on a mis en place je dirais des
frontières à dix kilomètres de chez soi
mais on est incapable de repenser le
sujet des frontières comme sous l'angle
de la protection voyait sous toujours on
pense les frontières sous l'angle de la
fermeture et jamais on les pense sous
l'angle de la protection et là il ya un
vrai problème parce que concrètement
aujourd'hui ce qui rend impossible
l'assimilation des immigrés c'est le
phénomène de nombre et quand justement
on n'est pas en mesure de partager et de
s'assimiler de partager ce qui fait je
dirais la définition du pays d'accueil
eh bien on assiste à des phénomènes de
repli identitaire on assiste à des
phénomènes de radicalisation on assiste
à des phénomènes aussi qui sont en lien
avec la pauvreté à la fois culturel et
économique et finalement tout ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui dans le terrorisme dans
les insurrections urbaine c'est le
reflet de cela et quand moi j'entends
monsieur le premier ministre quand
j'entends le ministre de l'intérieur
quand j'entends le porte parole du
gouvernement qui dit surtout on est à
mille lieues voir masse en milieu je
crois disait l'un d'eux de faire un lien
entre immigration et terrorisme mais
qu'on ouvre les yeux qu'on ouvre les
yeux parce que allumer les bougies ça
suffit plus quoi faire faire des beaux
discours qui qui voilà qui sont à chaque
fois je dirais des discours d'après coup
c'est comme si vous voulez on se disait
bien quand je vois que mon compte en
banque et est dans le rouge bien c'est
sûr que si j'attends la fin du mois pour
le regarder je ne vais pas assister
passivement à cette lamentation là il ya
vraiment il ya vraiment besoin d'engager
une volonté politique pour être à même
de poser des solutions qui encore une
fois existe déjà
stéphanie elle a été décorée de la
légion d'honneur à titre posthume et le
sénat lui a rendu hommage le 5 mai il
n'y a pas que le terrorisme qui menace
les services publics français on a
appris qu'en avril dernier des policiers
du commissariat d'elancourt et de
trappes notamment
avait été attaqué la police est elle
devenue une cible privilégiée
bien sûr bien sûr parce que la police
c'est l'ordre c'est l'autorité est dès
lors que les policiers justement sont
dans leur rôle ils sont les derniers
remparts contre cette barbarie qui
s'exerce de la délinquance au terrorisme
et nos forces de l'ordre paient un lourd
tribut depuis plusieurs années
maintenant particulièrement dans les
yvelines
mais les policiers ont peur aussi on
parle on par exemple des rodéos de motos
c'est la même chose
moi c'est un sujet que j'avais déjà
abordé avec avec des policiers du
commissariat de guyancourt qui me disait
vous savez intercepté des motos quand il
ya des rodéos c'est mettre en danger nos
propres moteurs et on voit bien
aujourd'hui que la police prend des
risques considérables pour nous protéger
nous et elle en paie le prix
et j'ai compris mon protégé ce qui nous
protège protéger ce qui nous protège
encore une fois c'est d'abord faire
respecter la loi quand des policiers
interceptent met en garde à vue et que
la justice derrière relâche au motif
qu'il ya des circonstances atténuantes
regardez l affaire halimi
l'irresponsabilité pénale il va falloir
aussi qu'on ouvre à nouveau ce dossier
parce que il ya déjà des critères
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont pas ce qu'ils
étaient je dirais qu'il avait animé la
loi toujours en vigueur mais clairement
un délinquant est un assassin sous
l'emprise de la drogue et bien est ce
que c'est si simple que ça de dire qu'il
n'est pas responsable
et puis quand par ailleurs on ouvre le
débat de la légalisation du cannabis
il ya des ya des contradictions qui sont
absolument intolérable dans ce dans ce
contexte là si douloureux alors
revenons-en aux mesures gouvernementales
pour faire face à l'épidémie de kobe de
19 depuis le début du mois de mai la
vaccination est élargi à tous les
adultes de plus de 55 ans mais aussi à
partir de 18 ans pour les personnes
atteintes de comorbidité depuis le 12
mai la vaccination accélère puisque le
président a annoncé qu'il serait
possible de prendre rendez vous le jour
pour le lendemain quel que soit l'âge
au cas où des doses seraient inutilisés
en fin de journée au 7 mai 16 3 millions
de personnes ont reçu au moins une dose
du vaccin et 7,3 sur un an ce rêve accès
ni complètement première question quel
est votre regard sur la vaccination dans
le département dans le département on a
été je pense aux avant-gardes grâce à
une organisation à une souplesse dans
l'organisation territoriale et c'est là
qu'on voit que les élus locaux
depuis le début un an 7 dans cette crise
du coc vides sont finalement les mieux à
même d'y répondre d'abord parce qu'ils
connaissent les besoins ils connaissent
les situations
ils savent identifier aussi les mesures
à prendre pour répondre aux besoins
spécifiques des différents types de
populations qui ont besoin d'être d'être
vacciné donc je pense qu'avec ce qu'on a
ce qu'on a réussi à mettre en place
autour de la dynamique créée par jean
michel fourgous au vaccinodromes de
saint quentin
on peut vraiment dire qu'on a été un
territoire d'innovation comme il aime à
le dire lui-même
maintenant ce sujet de la vaccination
qui est une des réponses à la crise du
coc vide ne doit pas faire oublier qu'il
ya aussi d'autres réponses qui pour le
coup on était complètement négligé et là
je m'exprime au nom dirait des médecins
libéraux des médecins de ville que je
rencontre sur notre territoire et qui
nous disent finalement dans cet épisode
depuis le début on nous a quasiment
les au sens où on vous a pas simplement
mis un masque mais on nous a aussi dénué
du bon sens qui est celui de notre
expérience parce que on a été dans une
logique de prévention uniquement d'un
point de vue izier nist et pas d'un
point de vue médical va dire qu'on n'a
pas cherché où nous a pas incités où on
nous a pas conforté dans notre volonté
de peut-être pas soigné le coc vide en
tant que tel mais d'en soigner les
conséquences ou de même les anticiper et
de faire en sorte qu'on ne taille pas va
vers des formes de co vide
longue de kovy grave et les médecins
généralistes alerte là dessus en disant
ce serait une erreur stratégique de
penser la lutte contre le coc vide
uniquement sous l'angle de la
vaccination la médecine heureusement
appris depuis pasteur bien sûr mais elle
a aussi appris notamment par exemple à
renforcer les défenses immunitaires et
donc on ne sera vainqueur de cette de
cette terrible maladie que si on a le la
souplesse finalement de d'utiliser
différents moyens différents outils pour
lutter contre
concernant la stratégie gouvernementale
le 19 mai ce sera la réouverture des
lieux culturels terrasse est enceinte
sportive
le couvre feu sera décalée à 21h puis le
9 juin encore un décalage du couvre-feu
à 23h le 30 juin date prévue du retour à
la normale sous condition bien entendu
ce sera en fonction du taux d'incidence
de l'épidémie il devra être en dessous
des 400 cas pour 100000 habitants pour
vous laurence rochât us est un copier
coller de l'année dernière avec une
réouverture durant la période estivale
pour faire plaisir aux français avant le
retour des restrictions alors c'est pas
simplement faire plaisir aux français
moi je pense aussi à tous les français
qui ont pas les moyens de se faire
plaisir parce que concrètement notre
économie souffre elle a souffert
terriblement nous au niveau du
département nous avons aider les
communes à aider les commerçants puisque
les maires avaient pu identifier dans
leur ville quelles étaient les commerces
qui avaient le plus souffert et nous en
tant que département nous n'avons pas là
comme la compétence économique mais nous
avons ce devoir des deux communes
parce qu'il ya vraiment cette solidarité
entre communes et départements et notre
manière d'y répondre précisément ça a
été
de proposer au maire de travailler main
dans la main pour repérer quelles
étaient les commerçants difficultés et
venir à leurs aides de manières au moins
à ce qu'on puisse leur permettre
d'assurer les charges fixes qui sont les
leurs alors ensuite oui les français en
ont marre on en a tous marre de vivre de
vivre masquée de vivre contraint de
rester chez soi dans certains dans
certain volume horaire contre 1,2 au
télétravail
on voit très bien aussi les drames que
génère l'isolément moi j'ai appris dans
que dans les lycées de mon fils cette
semaine et un garçon de seconde en 16
ans qui s'est suicidée de 16 ans qui
s'est suicidée je suis pas à même de
dire que ça a un rapport direct avec
avec l' isolement du coc vide mais on
voit bien qu'il ya tout un contexte
d'isolement qui fait que les personnes
les plus fragiles évidemment sont les
premières exposées donc il ya nécessité
de ne plus bloquer notre économie
d'apprendre à vivre avec ce virus comme
on le dit depuis le début
mais apprendre à vivre avec ce virus
c'est aussi apprendre à vivre avec
l'idée de la mort qu'on veut absolument
évacués de notre vie puisque par exemple
les sujets liés à l'euthanasie ce n'est
rien d'autre que de ne pas vouloir voir
la mort de ne pas vouloir reconnaître ce
qui fait partie de notre vie comme le
com comme on peut on peut quand même le
dire et est aujourd'hui on a on a eu une
stratégie de confinement qui était
finalement l'aveu d'un échec c'est parce
qu'on n'avait pas réussi à faire
autrement qu on a confiné donc oui bien
sûr il faut des confiné mais en 30 ans
en tirant les leçons des échecs de ses
premiers confinement déconfinement parce
que sinon c'est sans fin c'est important
de les confiner
mais est ce que c'est important de des
confiné de tout lâcher d'un coup vous
avez pas peur d'un laisser-aller sais
pas ce qui est prévu
de toute façon là il ya un déconfinement
par étapes alors dans la cohérence
effectivement peut interpeller aussi
parce que quand on a confiné
on était à trois mille cas aujourd'hui
on est à cinq mille je crois un peu
moins de 5000 et ont des consignes donc
il ya aussi cette crédibilité de la
deûle à delà de la parole publique qui
est mise en jeu
parce que bien souvent on se dit bien il
ya des mesures qui sont prises et qui ne
semble pas rationnellement fondées je
prends l'exemple du masque en extérieur
ça revient aujourd'hui dans l'est dans
les nombreuses interrogations
mais de fait est ce que c'est bien
fondées scientifiquement de porter un
masque en extérieur justement le débat
du port du masque est ce qu'il doit
rester obligatoire en extérieur il y est
vous d'accord avec ceux qui préconisent
de faire confiance aux français en les
laissant sans masque en extérieur mais
en le gardant dans la poche et quand ils
voient une afflux de l'affluence leur
maître naturel et ça ça fait appel à la
responsabilité et c'est évidemment la
solution la solution idéale parce que
les français on en marre d'être
infantilisés et et puis encore une fois
s'il ne suivent pas les mesures c'est la
plupart du temps parce que ces mesures
ne sont pas scientifiquement fondées nos
soupes ne sont donc pas rationnellement
fondé et au bout d'un moment je dirais
faut arrêter de nous prendre pour des
idiots
donc bien sûr faire appel à la
responsabilité individuelle me semble la
meilleure réponse pour ne pas augmenter
encore ce ras-le-bol
parce que vous savez quand on tire trop
d'un côté il ya un retour de balancier
terrible et toutes les fêtes sauvages
qu'on a pu
voilà qui ont qui ont égrainé
l'actualité était quelque part
l'expression de ce rap de ce ras-le-bol
je suis pas là en train de les justifier
je suis simplement en train de dire
attention quand on gouverne en muselant
est bien quand la bouche s'ouvre
malheureusement c'est pas forcément pour
dire des belles choses
serait-il logique donc de voir les
départements les plus touchés gardiez
des restrictions strictes pendant que le
reste du pays soient allégées pensons au
petit village de campagne ou de montagne
où la densité de population est plus
faible
si on vous dit au sortir de l'été que
les yvelines doivent se recombiner est
ce que ce serait normal mais aujourd'hui
je peux pas dire si ce serait normal ou
si ce serait pas normal dans la mesure
où j'ai pas les éléments qui
permettraient de de prendre une décision
simplement laisser cette souplesse
territoriales c'est absolument
indispensable parce que ce serait mal
comprendre ce qu'est l'égalité que de
que d'estimer que pour paquet
discrimination parce que finalement
derrière c'est cette question là qui est
posée pour pâques et de discrimination
il vaut mieux punir tout le monde où il
vaut mieux niveler par le bas et
et effectivement sur une île où où il ya
une densité de population très faible
l'hiver ou à l'automne les obliger aux
mêmes règles que celles d'une grande
métropole ça n'aurait absolument aucun
sens parlons si vous voulez bien des
élections départementales et régionales
qui approchent
comment vous placez vous pour ces
élections je ne me place pas j'ai fait
le choix justement de ne pas concourir
cette fois-ci non pas que je n'aurai que
j'aurais souhaité voilà décliner mais
tout simplement parce que l'équipe qui
s'est constitué et et qui comporte en
son sein des personnes pour lesquelles
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration et même
d'amitié s'est élargi à des membres qui
ne sont absolument pas de notre famille
politique et qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les politiques que par ailleurs nous
pouvons dénoncer au niveau national et
la clarté et la cohérence ont toujours
été pour moi d'aider vraiment des des
valeurs dans mon engagement politique
donc je ne cautionnerai pas ses choix et
donc je dirais je ne trouve pas ma place
dans cette équipe qui de toute façon ne
serait pas m'en trouver non plus parce
que je n'ai pas l'intention de de mettre
sous le tapis ce qui fonde mon
engagement et qui est animé par des
convictions fortes
alors est ce que le mouvement
conservateur va soutenir les
républicains alors le moi je fais partie
de la ceni de la commission nationale
d'investiture des républicains donc j'ai
eu l'occasion de m'exprimer cette
semaine encore et puis les semaines
passées sur les dossiers qui nous ont
été soumis pour les régionales notamment
et c'est à cette occasion que j'ai pris
une décision assez forte qui a été de ne
pas accorder mon soutien à renaud
muselier nous étions peu nombreux il est
vrai a opté pour pour ce choix
mais encore une fois c'est celui de la
clarté de la cohérence on ne peut pas
d'un côté fricoter avec en marche en
dénoncer la politique gouvernementale
qui liquident la france on a parlé des
sujets sécuritaires on a parlé du
terrorisme
on a parlé aussi des sujets sanitaires
donc on peut pas tenir ce discours là au
niveau national et validé en fermant les
yeux le fait que dans nos territoires si
aujourd'hui nous ouvrons nos majorités
départementales ou régionales à en
marche
eh bien demain
nous leur fournissons les grands
électeurs qui seront à même de faire
basculer le sénat qui aujourd'hui est la
seule force d'opposition en france seule
force efficace bien sûr qu'on a des
députés à l'assemblée
mais ils ne sont pas majoritaires est ce
que justement tous ces mouvements entre
politique ça floute forcément la vision
des français
est ce que les prochaines élections vont
être un aperçu des présidentielles qui
arrivent en 2022 mais surtout ça dégoûte
surtout ça dégoûte moi je me suis pas
engagé en politique pour cent et les
français en ont ras-le-bol je veux dire
quand on voit tous les dossiers brûlants
qui qui agitent notre pays quand on voit
la vie quotidienne des français qui est
à ce point impact est bien évidemment
que ils attendent de la clarté parce que
aujourd'hui cette politique qui consiste
à valider le en même temps alors je ne
suis ni de droite ni de gauche mais je
peux aussi être élan et l'autre en même
temps c'est une liquidation de tous nos
repères c'est même un danger pour la
démocratie
parce que en démocratie dans une
élection il ya des gagnants il ya des
perdants et c'est pas en lait riz
pauline en avant même de concourir que
l'on pourra dire qu'on a qu'on a été
victorieux et je crains justement que en
juin que le 27 juin
eh bien il ya des victoires qui soit en
fait de véritables défaite sur le plan
démocratique on voit l'envi dans votre
mouvement de valoriser le modèle d'une
famille durable
quel est ce modèle ce modèle d'une
famille durable c'est d'abord considérer
que ce qu'on voit au quotidien et ça
pour le coup j'ai été bien placé pour le
voir durant ses six années de demandes à
départemental à la commission famille
et emploi affaires familiales et
sociales tout ce qu'on voit de détresse
vient parfois et souvent de familles qui
ont été éclatées pour x raisons et des
raisons sur lesquelles je ne pose
absolument aucun jugement de valeur mais
c'est bien évident que la famille
durable c'est une famille qui est à même
de d'accueillir des enfants dans des
conditions matérielles et juridique qui
les protègent le mariage ça n'est rien
d'autre qu'un contrat le mariage c'est
pas ce pas une histoire d'amour pour le
pour le législateur foyer c'est le
contrat à partir duquel on va garantir
aux deux époux et aux enfants qui
naissent de leur union une structure à
même d'être une rampe de lancement dans
la vie et c'est pour ça que je suis
attachée au mariage civil comme étant
justement cette cette structure qui
protège vous êtes opposé à la pma la
procréation médicalement assistée à ce
propos le ministre de la santé au lit et
veyran a annoncé lundi 3 mai que les
premiers bébés nés de pma d'un couple de
femmes ou d'une femme seule naîtra avant
la fin du mandat d' emmanuel macron y
croyez vous et quel est votre avis sur
ça mais c'est surtout pas la priorité
c'est surtout pas la priorité faire des
lois pour répondre à des désirs
individuels que je peux comprendre le
désir de maternité évidemment en tant
que femme je le comprends mais mais le
sujet c'est pas ça aujourd'hui
voyez si à chaque fois que des désirs
individuels
quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs nécessite
de faire une loi mais on détourne en
fait le rôle du parlement on détourne le
rôle du parlement la loi elle doit être
valable pour tous est aujourd'hui venir
parler de de pma qui encore une fois
correspond à une à une à une minorité de
demandes pour des femmes des femmes en
couple alors qu'il ya des urgences
telles que celles dont on a pu débattre
au début de cette émission notamment de
déduire des urgences en termes de
protection des français protection
économique protection vis-à-vis du
terrorisme régulation de l'immigration
je veux dire aujourd'hui une politique
ça doit se faire autour de priorités et
je pense que c'est là que la droite a
peut-être justement quelque chose à a à
dire parce que il y a urgence
aujourd'hui voyez il ya urgence à à
conserver en france ce qui est sans
cesse détruits depuis le quinquennat
d'emmanuel mc ren est liquidé la famille
c'est derrière en payer les conséquences
dans nos services sociaux je précise que
la pma s'adresse pour le moment aux
couples hétérosexuels en âge de procréer
si l'un des membres présentent une
stérilité pathologique médicaments
constatés ou est porteur d'une maladie
grave pouvant être transmises aux
conjoints ou à l'enfant en 2017 le
mouvement conservateur avait fait
campagne pour françois fillon qui
allez-vous soutenir en 2022 est ce que
valérie pécresse pourrait être la
personne que vous allez soutenir
vous savez on a fait une grande
consultation il ya un an deux cent
quarante mille participation
consultation avec avec nos moyens du
bord nous sommes un petit parti
politique aussi qui n'a pas donc de
grands moyens mais cette consultation a
été un succès nous avons interrogé les
français sur les principes qui pour eux
comptent dans la vie et sur les
propositions concrètes à même de les
mettre en oeuvre
deux cent quarante mille participation
de là est né un manifeste d'une
cinquante pas de 50 pages qui qui
propose en fait justement les mesures
prioritaires pour la france et nous
avons pris notre bâton de pèlerin pour
aller rencontrer les parlementaires les
députés les sénateurs les présidents
d'exécutifs dans les régions etc et
toute personne qui qui nous en faisait
la demande parce qu on a aussi eu
beaucoup de demandes de rendez vous et
c'est sur cette base là qu'en fait nous
regarderons
le programme et le projet pour la france
mais il ya déjà trois grandes lignes qui
se dessine
la france est une nation c'est une
nation donc avec avec des frontières
avec une géographie c c'est donc une
souveraineté nationale qu'il faut être
en mesure de garantir à l'instar de
voilà ou plutôt à l'opposé de ce que
emmanuel macron demande d'une france qui
finalement serait une start up nation
une une france ouverte à tous vents est
incapable de garantir la sécurité la
protection la france c'est aussi une
nation qui est héritière d'une
civilisation héritière d'une manière de
vivre à la française
bien loin du multiculturalisme
d'emmanuel macron qui affirment qu'il
n'y a pas de culture en france et qui du
coup est prêt finalement à renier notre
histoire à renier nos modes de vie
pourvu qu'on soit le plus accueillant
possible y compris à ceux qui ne
partagent pas notre culture et nos modes
de vie et qui entendent nous les imposer
et puis la france c'est aussi une nation
qui qui a je dirais ce souci de la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
nature humaine en préservant également
la beauté des paysages parce que je suis
très attaché à la fois au patrimoine
naturel patrimoine humain et au
patrimoine culturel et donc sur la base
de ces trois grands axes la et bien nous
examinerons
le projet est le candidat qui sera à
même de le porter en justement en
regardant aussi sa cohérence sa
cohérence dans les choix des élections
intermédiaires départementales
régionales
parce que je pense qu à un an d'écart on
ne pourra pas fermer les yeux sur les
choix qui auront été faits moi je dis
toujours quand je vois la montre moi qui
sont tes amis et je te dirai qui tu es
c'est un petit peu sous cet angle là que
je regarderai nos candidats aux
régionales valérie pécresse en 2022
pourrait être une solution je rappelle
que vous êtes toutes les deux des
yvelines
exactement est ce que pour vous c'est
important aussi de soutenir une femme
vous savez souvent la parité la parité
qui est évidemment une avancée elle sert
aussi de prétexte c'est à dire que l'on
ne peut pas juger de la compétence d'une
personne en fonction de son sexe se
serait finalement le pire féminisme que
de faire ça ce serait même nier
l'égalité fondamentale entre un homme et
une femme l'égalité je dirais de dignité
et de nature entre un homme et une femme
donc donc choisir une femme n'est pas
pour moi un critère de compétence pas
plus que choisir un homme très
rapidement pour finir vous projeter sur
cet été dans le département on va
remettre en place dans le département
notamment tous les soutiens qu'ils ont
été
valider l'année dernière pour que les
élus les yvelinois qui ne partent pas en
vacances et qu'ils ne puissent pas
qu'ils ne pourront pas partir en
vacances puissent bénéficier d'un
accompagnement comme on l'a fait en
juillet et août dernier parce que c'est
notre rôle en tant que co département
d'être au plus proche des besoins
d'abord de pouvoir les identifier
et c'est en cela que le département est
un acteur absolument capital de delà de
la vie du quotidien
merci à vous laurence trochut d'avoir
participé à cet hebdo politique en
association avec tv 60,18 je rappelle
que vous êtes conseillère départementale
des yvelines et présidente du mouvement
conservateur merci merci à vous tous
ceux l'hebdo politique c'est fini pour
ce dimanche je rappelle que vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission podcast audio
et vidéo sur le site internet et
l'application radio sensations
bonne soirée à tous et à dimanche
prochain pour un nouvel hebdo politique
[Musique]
lève tôt politique